Ich bin wirklich froh, hier zu sein,
vielen Dank an Marco und dich, dass du mich eingeladen hast. Ich
muss ziemlich bald nach meinem Vortrag gehen,
und hier im Flugzeug
dachte ich, das muss eine der dümmsten
Entscheidungen sein, die ich je getroffen habe  Es war so, als würde das
ganze verwüstete Deutschland für fünf
Stunden Konferenz kommen, aber ich bin wirklich
froh, dass ich das gemacht habe, nicht zuletzt, weil ich
Future the Van Inwagen und Richard
Swinburne zum ersten Mal am selben
Tag treffen kann, also weißt du, das ist alles  gut,
aber ich habe es auch als Vorwand benutzt, um
zwei meiner Lieblingszeitungen in der Vorveröffentlichung noch einmal zu
lesen, nämlich diese beiden täglichen Blausten. Sind
wir frei, die Gesetze zu brechen?
Essay, der jemals
in defensivem Kompatibilismus geschrieben wurde, und er
sagt auch in einem Artikel von 2008, dass am Ende
hier mein abschließender Ratschlag steht, aber
kompatibel als Studie sind wir frei,
die Gesetze vorsichtig zu brechen, das ist der Weg,
ein Kompatibilist zu sein, den
ich nicht bin  Ich bin mir absolut sicher, dass das der Weg ist
, ein Wettkämpfer zu sein  titiveness, aber ich bin mir ziemlich
sicher, dass so etwas der Weg ist,
mit dem Konsequenz-Argument umzugehen, wenn
Sie ein kompatibler Issed sind, und
darüber werde ich sprechen und darüber, dass
einer meiner anderen auch in Lieblingspapieren
über den freien Willen ist  Fanning Ridings antwortet auf
Lewis' Artikel mit dem Titel Freiheit,
die Gesetze zu brechen. Ein Grund, warum er einer meiner
Lieblingsartikel zum Thema Willensfreiheit ist, ist, dass er
eine Tugend zeigt, die wir in der Philosophie
öfter zeigen könnten, als wir
meinen, nämlich es mit dem Gegner aufzunehmen
ihrem Heimatgebiet, also ist es ein Papier
, das eher als die Leute dazu neigt,
das Argument der Konsequenzen als ein
potenzielles Knockdown-Argument zu betrachten,
das den Kompatibilismus vollständig widerlegt, und jetzt können
wir darüber streiten, ob es erfolgreich ist
oder nicht
Für die
erste Hälfte des Papiers ist, dass
Sie fast nie niedergeschlagene
Argumente in der Philosophie richtig bekommen, das ist
einfach nicht das richtige Gewicht, um
über den Weg für den Cerv nachzudenken  logische Argumente
funktionieren und Lewis' positive Sichtweise, wie er
sie in der Einführung zu
philosophical papers vol 1 beschreibt,
weil es sozusagen keine niederschmetternden Argumente gibt, werden
wir am Ende mit
verschiedenen Leuten enden, die verschiedene
Arten von globalen Positionen in der Philosophie besetzen,
und zwar so gut wir können  Unsere Hoffnung ist es,
alle unsere eigenen Meinungen ins
Gleichgewicht zu bringen, und wenn
Sie Ihre Position ins Gleichgewicht bringen, müssen Sie
die Herausforderungen berücksichtigen
, die durch die Argumente anderer Menschen aufgeworfen werden,
und darüber nachdenken, ob Ihre
Ansicht einige Konsequenzen hat  Sie sind
nicht bereit zu tolerieren und
verlangen daher von Ihnen, dass Sie Ihre Meinung in
irgendeiner Weise revidieren, und das ist der Geist, in dem
Van Inwagen handelt. Sind wir frei, die Gesetze zu brechen?
darüber nachzudenken, was das kostet, was
die Kostenlast für jemanden ist, der
den Louis II kaufen will, und darauf zu antworten
, das ist eines meiner
Lieblingspapiere  freier Wille, weil
es das auf eine wirklich nette Art und Weise tut, also bin ich ein
Amerikaner im hohen Geist von Louisiana und
behauptet, dass der Preis für
Kompatibilismus zu hoch ist, da er dazu führt, dass
deterministische Agenten in der Lage sind,
Wunder zu vollbringen, das ist seine grundlegende Sorge, der ich jetzt nicht
zustimme  das, aber ich weiß absolut,
dass ich keine
unvereinbaren Anhänger davon überzeugen werde, eine
Vielfalt als Antwort anzunehmen, weil ich bin, dass dies niemals
passieren wird, also interessiert mich irgendwie,
was die zugrunde liegende
Quelle der Meinungsverschiedenheit in all diesem Ich ist
glaube nicht, dass dem
Kompatibilisten etwas völlig
Unangenehmes aufgebürdet wird, aber es stellt sich immer noch die Frage,
was die relevanten Kosten und
Vorteile auf beiden Seiten sind,
also werde ich
gegen Ende darauf eingehen, und ich gehe  zu fragen,
ob es einen Preis für den
inkompatiblen Sime gibt, würde im Grunde zu dem
Schluss kommen, dass, wenn Sie
eine bestimmte Art von inkompatiblem Iss sind, wenn Sie eine bestimmte Art von
Inkompatibilität haben,
und Louis 'Antwort darauf ablehnen
Wenn wir es aus einem bestimmten
Grund besitzen, sind wir
an diesem Punkt wirklich nur in eine Art Pattsituation geraten. Ich
glaube wirklich nicht,
dass es auf beiden Seiten etwas zu sagen gibt, das die
andere Seite fern fühlen lässt  geneigt,
ihre Ansicht darüber zu revidieren und
einigermaßen richtig, es ist nicht so, als wäre eine Seite
völlig unvernünftig und der Eintritt in
Ordnung, also werde ich das nicht durchgehen.
Ich bin sicher, Sie sind alle damit vertraut,
hier ist das Argument der Konsequenz, wenn
Determinismus ist  wahr dann die volle pax
über den fernen geldbeutel und die gesetze und
sag das ich geschmack zum frühstück auf
meer hatte ich musste die platten nicht ein
bisschen probieren lass uns so tun als hätte ich es getan oh sorry es
sollten p0 fakten über die vergangenheit und
die gesetze sein  dazu führen, dass ich Toast zum
Frühstück hatte,
aber ich war nicht in der Lage,
diese Tatsache über die Vergangenheit falsch zu machen, ich konnte
die Tatsachen über die
Verbindung der Gesetze nicht
falsch machen, also konnte ich ihre Verbindung nicht erzwingen, also
w
Da ich die Konsequenz dieser Konjunktion Biere, die
ich zum Frühstück hatte, falsch machen konnte,
konnte ich nichts anderes tun, als den
Toast zu haben, worauf ich mich konzentrieren werde, ist, dass
ich nicht in der Lage war, die
Konjunktion der Gesetze zu machen  Teil,
weil Lewis sich darauf konzentriert, also werde ich
Louis' Antwort für diejenigen unter Ihnen,
die damit nicht vertraut sind, ziemlich schnell durchgehen, also ist Lewis' Ansicht,
wie sie in diesem Papier verankert ist,
als lokaler Wunderkompatibilismus bekannt geworden
und die Ansicht, dass es so ist  nicht wirklich eine
kompatibilistische Position Ich meine,
insbesondere erzählt er uns keine Geschichte
darüber, was Fähigkeiten sind. Er sagt viel
darüber aus, welche Fähigkeiten wir haben und welche
nicht  ist es dort, wo es
keine Theorie ist, sondern eine Möglichkeit
, auf das Konsequenz-Argument zu reagieren,
so dass Lewis 'Zeile so aussieht, dass die
Prämisse, die ich nicht falsch machen konnte, die
Gesetze nur mehrdeutig sind, es gibt eine schwache
Lesart der Prämisse w  er sagt, ich war
nicht in der Lage, so etwas zu tun, wenn ich es
getan hätte, wäre ein Wunder geschehen.
Lewis denkt, dass Prämissen, wenn sie so gelesen werden
, die Prämisse einfach falsch sind
Wenn meine Tat alles ein Wunder verursacht hätte, wäre es
eher ein Fall, in dem ein Wunder
geschehen wäre, in der Tat, es
omocha wiederholte sich leicht, bevor ich
die Aktion ausführte. Ich war nicht in der Lage, irgendetwas zu tun, was
meine Tat getan hätte, wenn ich es getan
hätte  Alles ein Wunder verursacht Lewis
denkt, dass Praktiken, die so gelesen werden,
die Prämisse wahr ist, also wenn wir
die Prämisse jetzt auf die schwache Weise lesen, ist sie falsch,
also ist das Konsequenz-Argument vollkommen
gültig, aber es ist nur
so, dass es eine falsche Prämisse hat, wenn wir das lesen
Prämisse auf die starke Weise, gut, die
Prämisse ist wahr, aber sie macht das
Konsequenzargument ungültig,
weil es einfach nicht
aus allen anderen Prämissen folgt, zusammen
mit der Behauptung, dass ich nicht in der Lage war, dies zu
tun  Wenn ich es getan
hätte, wäre meine App natürlich ein Wunder
gewesen, das ich nicht konnte, sonst warum ist
das so gut, weil es nicht wahr ist, dass
ich nicht in der Lage war, so etwas zu tun, dass
ein Wunder geschehen wäre, wenn ich es getan hätte
Richtig, also klären Sie diese Prämisse, und
dann enden Sie so oder so mit
einem Argument, das nicht stichhaltig ist. Also hier ist die
Idee, dass es zwei Arten von Fähigkeiten gibt
, die Agenten haben könnten. Sie könnten
die schwache Fähigkeit haben,
etwas zu tun, wo ich -  a
wäre ein Wunder geschehen, aber vor
a wäre es kein Wunder gewesen, das
meine Handlung oder eine ihrer Auswirkungen gewesen wäre
, das ist eine Fähigkeit, von der Lewis glaubt,
dass deterministische Agenten im Allgemeinen
haben, oder Sie könnten eine starke Fähigkeit haben,
die die Fähigkeit ist  Etwas
so zu machen, dass wir I to aa selbst oder ein
Effekt davon sind, wäre ein Wunder, und
Lewis denkt, dass wir keine starken
Fähigkeiten haben, richtig, das ist die Idee, also ist das
jetzt nur eine Art Aufwärmung dessen, was
Rafi tut  Alles, was Sie über Lewis wissen müssen,
über kontrafaktische Fakten, damit
dies alles funktioniert. Frage, was
passiert wäre, wenn ich nicht einen DAT T gehabt hätte, wenn ich
heute Morgen um acht Uhr keinen Toast gehabt hätte. Nun,
was wäre passiert, wenn ich
keinen Toast gehabt hätte?  Vieles ist heute Morgen
auf der nächstmöglichen Welt passiert,
wo es mir leid tat. Oh, was
passiert wäre, wenn ich keinen Toast gehabt hätte, ist das,
was auf der nächstmöglichen Welt passiert ist,
wo ich Toast zum Frühstück hatte.
Ich habe es gerade umgedreht  zwischen a und not a
tut mir leid,
also was ist diese nächstmögliche Welt,
wo ich die Vergangenheit dieser Welt mag,
ist genau die gleiche wie in der
tatsächlichen Welt, bis kurz vor der
fraglichen Zeit, kurz vor 8 Uhr
, bis es sein könnte  Gerade an dem Punkt, an dem ich
denke, dass ihr vielleicht Geschmack daran habt, bin ich mir
nicht sicher, und dann passiert ein Divergenzwunder
auf dieser Welt, so dass es so
aussieht, als würden die Gesetze der tatsächlichen Welt
in dieser Welt verletzt, genau da
gibt es einen kleinen Fehler in den Gesetzen der tatsächlichen
Welt
Die Gesetze der tatsächlichen Welt sind also nicht die
Gesetze von W, weil sie nicht einmal
wahre W sind, aber bis dahin war die
Vergangenheit bis zu diesem Zeitpunkt genau gleich,
so dass das Divergenzwunder M
mit der Vergangenheit der tatsächlichen Welt
und den Gesetzen danach nicht vereinbar ist  Was passiert, ist
, dass diese Welt W nach den Gesetzen der tatsächlichen Welt abläuft, so als
wären die
Gesetze bei W alle gleich, abgesehen von
diesem kleinen Ausrutscher, und die Vergangenheit von W ist
genau die gleiche wie der Übergang zur
tatsächlichen Welt, danach geht es
dank dieses kleinen blips immer mehr auseinander zu
gehen rechts ich habe toast ich
habe toast im bauch da liegt eine
scheibe brot weniger auf dem tisch die
anderen gäste im hotel werden richtig
wütend weil es keinen toast gibt lachen und
beschweren sich beim manager  und so ist es
, wie Sie wissen, verbreitet sich das, also ist
die nächste Welt so, wo ich
keine Kleidung zum Frühstück hatte, richtig
okay, also unter der Annahme von Determinismus
muss es ein Wunder aus dieser Welt geben, richtig,
also ich e  Ich habe das als Folge
von ws Vergangenheit und Gesetzen getan, so Lewis, außer
dass uns die starken Fähigkeiten fehlten, oder
die Fähigkeit, etwas zu tun, so dass ich, wenn
ich es täte, ein Wunder vollbringen oder bewirken würde,
aber er denkt, dass
wir schwach sind  Fähigkeiten Ich war in der Lage,
Müsli zum Frühstück zu haben, das heißt, ich hätte
etwas tun können,
hätte ich es getan, wäre kurz zuvor ein Wunder geschehen,
und das hätte dazu geführt,
dass ich Toast zum
Frühstücksmüsli als Referenz hätte, damit ich
es hätte rendern können  Die Verbindung
der tatsächlichen Gesetze erzwingt im schwachen Sinne,
dass ich etwas hätte tun können,
dass die tatsächlichen Gesetze nicht wahr gewesen wären, wenn ich es getan hätte.
Hier ist Manny Morgans
Reaktion auf Louis 'Argumentationslinie.
Dann ist das Wesentliche der Preis für
Kompatibilismus  ist einfach zu hoch, also
versucht er, Lewis mit einer
Konsequenz zu satteln, von der ich annehme, dass die Idee
aussieht, dass sie von jedermanns Lichtern ungenießbar sein sollte,
Sie wissen, ob Sie
eine kompatible Liste sind oder  Nicht nur, dass Sie
einfach nicht saugen können,
also hier ist ein Teil von dem, was er sagt, freier Wille
in einer deterministischen Welt
impliziert strikt die Fähigkeit, Wunder zu
vollbringen  Alle diese Welten,
alle freien Agenten, sind in der Lage,
Wunder
zu vollbringen  Was zu sagen ist,
es ist zunächst nicht sofort klar, was
los ist, also dachten wir zuerst, wir
könnten uns den ganzen Punkt
von Louis 'Papier ansehen, der besagt, dass wir nach allem
Gericht frei sind, die Gesetze zu brechen,
dass die Antwort auf diese Frage ist, dass wir
frei sind  Die Gesetze zu brechen ist ja
und nein, es hängt davon ab, was Sie unter
den Gesetzen brechen verstehen, also sprechen Sie
davon, die Fähigkeit zu haben, dies zu tun  Wenn Sie
so etwas tun würden, wäre
alles kaputt gegangen. Reden Sie von der
Fähigkeit, tatsächlich ein Wunder zu vollbringen,
und Lewis denkt, es gibt einen Sinn, in
dem wir frei sind, sie richtig zu brechen, wir
haben schwache Verse und einen Sinn, in dem wir
Wenn wir also keine starken Fähigkeiten haben, zu
sagen, dass die Freiheit, Gesetze zu brechen, eine
Folge von Selbstkompatibilismus ist, ist es eine
Art, diese Unterscheidung zu ignorieren, von der
Sie vielleicht denken, dass Sie vielleicht wieder
denken, dass der ganze Sinn dieser
Unterscheidung darin bestand, das zu vermeiden
Schlussfolgerung des Konsequenz-Arguments,
ohne akzeptieren zu müssen, dass der freie Wille in der
deterministischen Welt die
Fähigkeit, ein Wunder zu vollbringen, strikt impliziert,
da die Fähigkeit, den Arm zu heben, unter
normalen Umständen die Fähigkeit ist,
etwas zu tun, das ein Wunder erfordert, aber
nicht die Fähigkeit, etwas zu tun  Eine Minute ein
Wunder, also könnten Sie sich Sorgen machen, dass das
, was passiert ist, darin besteht, dass Geld
einfach irgendwie ignoriert wurde, aber die zentrale
Unterscheidung von Louis 'Papier  Es ist
in Wirklichkeit nicht das, was vor sich geht,
also hier ist Lewis' Definition
eines Wunders der Wunder, eines Ereignisses,
das mit den tatsächlichen Gesetzen
nicht vereinbar ist, also gibt es keine Wunder auf der tatsächlichen
Welt, aber es gibt Wunder, mit
anderen Worten, dh es gibt Dinge
, die  Mit anderen Worten, die gegen
die Gesetze der Welt verstoßen, findet Vanilla
Morgan, dass diese Definition einfach zu
schwach ist und durch die
folgende Definition ersetzt werden sollte: Ein Wunder ist ein
Ereignis oder sagt zu den Paaren, die
geschehen,
würde nicht mit der ganzen
Wahrheit über das übereinstimmen  Vergangenheit und die
Naturgesetze jetzt, Sie können sehen, wohin wir damit gehen,
sobald Sie diese
Definition auf dem Tisch haben, was Sie getan haben,
ist, diese Unterscheidung
zunichte zu machen, die im Herzen von Louis 'Antwort liegt,
indem Sie annehmen, dass Determinismus meine Hand hebt  wird
sich als die
Leistung eines Wunders nach dieser
Definition herausstellen, nicht anders
als schneller zu laufen als Löffel zu biegen, alles
gleichermaßen wundersam  Nun, was ist das
Argument für die Behauptung, dass wir
Lewis' Vorstellung von einem Wunder aufgeben
und Van Inwagens Vorstellung
von einem Wunder folgen sollten? Es geht wie dieses lange
Zitat, angenommen, dass Elia, der sich
derzeit in Jerusalem befindet, behauptet, er
könne in zehn Minuten in Babylon sein
Nehmen wir nun weiter an, dass wir sein Publikum
in der Lage sind, ihn davon zu überzeugen, dass die
Naturgesetze und die ganze Wahrheit über die
Vergangenheit zusammen streng implizieren, dass
er in zehn Minuten nicht in Babylon sein wird,
dann muss Elia sicherlich entweder
seinen Anspruch zurückziehen, um dazu in der Lage zu sein  in zehn Minuten in Babylon sein
oder sonst behaupten
, ein Wunder vollbringen zu können, denn das wäre
es, wenn er in zehn Minuten in Babylon sein
würde, wenn die Vergangenheit und die
Gesetze zusammen dazu führen, dass
er nicht in Babylon zehn sein wird  Minuten von jetzt an
wäre es ein Wunder Es wäre ein Fehler
darauf zu bestehen, dass dies immer noch ein Phantom ist Es
wäre ein Fehler zu darauf zu bestehen, dass ein
Wunder als ein Ereignis definiert werden sollte,
dessen Eintreten sich ereignet  Vor Gericht wäre es unvereinbar
mit den Naturgesetzen
, so definiert Lewis es. Stellen Sie sich vor,
er sagt, dieser Austausch, ich kann keine
Wunder
vollbringen.  Kein
Wunder sein Ein Wunder ist ein Ereignis,
das den Naturgesetzen widerspricht, und
Ihr Aufenthalt in Babylon in zehn Minuten steht im
Einklang mit den Naturgesetzen, denn
die Naturgesetze haben nichts
darüber zu sagen, wer wann wo ist
ein Wunder sein, aber richtig, also hier ist der
Gedanke: Lewis' Definition von
Wunder in Übereinstimmung mit den Gesetzen ist
einfach zu eng,
es macht Elijahs Anspruch, in zehn Minuten in Babylon sein zu können, nicht
als Anspruch zu zählen, eins vollbringen zu können
Wunder, da Elia
zur Zeit t plus zehn in Babylon ist, widerspricht keinem
Naturgesetz,
also kein Wunder nach
Lewis 'Ansicht, aber es ist eine Behauptung, dass
es die Behauptung ist, dass er in der Lage ist
, Wunder zu vollbringen, also wir
Ich muss Lewis 'Konzeption des Wunders ablehnen und
die mehr Fan-in-Schnäppchen-
Konzeption eines Wunders übernehmen, die natürlich
alles, was deterministische Agenten
nicht tun, so macht,
dass es richtig ist, zu sagen, dass etwas anderes wirklich
immer ein Wunder beinhalten wird, also bin ich es jetzt
Ich werde eine wirklich, sehr schnelle Antwort darauf geben. Ich denke, es
gibt viel mehr darüber zu sagen
, als ich sagen werde, und ich lasse
alles viel einfacher erscheinen, als
es wirklich ist, aber im Interesse der Zeit.
Ich werde nur sehr
schnell drüber gleiten, also schreibt Shirley, dass es einen gesunden Menschenverstand gibt,
nach dem Elijahs Fähigkeit,
in 10 Minuten in Babylon zu sein, ein Wunder wäre,
richtig, ich möchte das irgendwie zugeben
, aber es ist so wirklich unvereinbar
damit  Lewis' Vorstellung von einem Wunder, und
ich glaube, es ist nicht so. Früher dachte ich, dass er
damit völlig recht hatte, und in einem
Aufsatz, den ich ungefähr zur gleichen Zeit schrieb,
habe ich eine Art alternative
Definition von wha  t Ich denke, was ich ein
gesetzesbrechendes Ereignis nenne, das genau
versucht, jene Fälle zu erfassen, in denen man
in 10 Minuten in Babylon ist,
die nach Lewis-Definition keine Wunder sind,
sondern davon
unterschieden werden müssen, den Arm zu heben und
ich '  Ich neige jetzt irgendwie zu der
Annahme, dass das komplizierter ist, als
es sein muss, also werde ich mich für
die direktere Antwort entscheiden. Schauen Sie sich die
Themen an, die Fähigkeit,
Wunder zu vollbringen, wenn Sie zur Zeit T in Babylon sind
es ist das
Ergebnis dessen, was
Elijah zu tun glaubt, das
ihn in 10 Minuten nach Babylon bringen wird, obwohl
er jetzt in Jerusalem ist
2 Minuten oder 5 Minuten oder
10 Minuten Zeit, vielleicht
glaubt er deshalb, dass er es tun kann, er wird einfach so
wie Dorothy in The Wizard of Oz und
das geht irgendwie  Für ihn
diese Handlungen auszuarbeiten, die Dee materialisiert und
rematerialisiert, um durch die
schiere Kraft des Gedankens irgendwohin zu gelangen, wären Wunder
direkt bei Louis 'Lichtern, die
den tatsächlichen Gesetzen widersprechen, dass jemand
spontan von einem Ort verschwindet und dann an einem anderen Ort
wieder auftaucht,
vorausgesetzt  Um dem Determinismus zu dienen, vielleicht
nicht im Determinismus anzunehmen, also ist Elias
Unfähigkeit, nach Babylon zu kommen,
als eine Aktion konzipiert, um
jede Aktion auszuführen, die erforderlich wäre
, damit er in zehn Minuten dort ist, es
ist die Unfähigkeit, ein Wunder zu vollbringen,
angesichts der Geschichte über Wunder  Wenn also
Elijah sagt, dass ich Wunder vollbringen kann, bin ich
zum Beispiel in der Lage, in zehn Minuten in Babylon zu sein.
Ich denke, wir können
ihn vernünftigerweise so interpretieren, dass Saad
eine fiktive Figur interpretiert, wir
können ihn vernünftigerweise so interpretieren, dass er bedeutet
, dass er etwas tun kann  Das zu
tun, wird zu diesem Zustand führen,
und eine solche Aktion wäre in der
Tat ein Wunder  Es scheint mir nicht
so, als ob der
gesunde Menschenverstand auch nur annähernd an den Rand der Belastungsgrenze dehnt. Wenn er also sagt, dass ich in der Lage bin, von jetzt an in Babylon zu sein,
denken wir an ihn, als würde er sagen, dass ich in der
Lage bin, etwas zu tun, das dazu führen wird, dass
ich es bin  in babylon in 10 minuten nach hause
, das lässt dich behaupten, dass du in der lage bist
, etwas wunderbares zu tun, okay, also
behaupte ich und ich sage, das geht alles ein bisschen schnell,
es ist komplizierter als das, ich
behaupte wirklich, dass die rechtfertigung, die van
inwagen für die annahme seiner definition gibt  Von einem
Wunder gibt es das, das
alles, was die Person gegen die
tatsächlichen Gesetze verstößt, nicht erfolgreich macht,
also hat Lewis Recht, dass das Eingeständnis, dass
deterministische Agenten in der Lage sind,
Wunder zu vollbringen, kein Preis ist, den der
Kompatibilist zahlen muss, richtig, Sie
müssen zahlen  Dieser Preis, wenn Sie glauben, dass die
deterministischen Agenten
in zehn Minuten nach Babylon gelangen oder
schneller als das Licht laufen können oder was auch immer, aber Lewis
glaubt das nicht und Kompatibilisten im
Allgemeinen müssen nicht daran denken  Aber
ich glaube nicht für eine Sekunde
, dass jeder Kompatibilist, der
das Konsequenz-Argument kauft, davon
überzeugt sein wird, dass er das
unterstützen sollte. Louis als Antwort auf die
Konsequenz-Argumente
Inkompatibel ist der Widerstand, ihn zu adoptieren
oder die niedrigere Antwort zu akzeptieren
, das ist die Frage, die mich wirklich
interessiert, also habe ich das jetzt sehr schlecht ausgedrückt,
weshalb da
drüben etwas an der Tafel steht, also legen Sie es
beiseite, um vor mir zu sprechen  Wunder, dass
jede kompatibilistische Antwort auf das
Konsequenz-Argument, das das
Leugnen der relevanten Prämisse beinhaltet, befürchtet, dass
jemand, den ich a nicht in der Lage bin, die niedrigste
Kraft zu geben, offensichtlich
behaupten muss, dass ich in gewissem Sinne tatsächlich in der
Lage bin, L falsch richtig zu machen, das ist genau
das  Leugnung, jetzt nehme ich es an, und ich bin
wirklich daran interessiert zu wissen, was
in der Raumsache unvereinbar ist, dass der
Roman diesen Mangel an
Begeisterung für lokale
Wunderkompanien unvereinbar macht  Tibilismus oder allgemein diese Art von
kompatibilistischer Antwort auf das
Konsequenz-Argument ist, dass Verleugnung
an und für sich einfach absurd ist,
egal wie viel fantasievolle Beinarbeit
wir Kompatibilisten tun, um zu versuchen, es
weniger verrückt erscheinen zu lassen, es ist einfach verrückt,
also ich weiß  Das Gerede, das Sie in
vitam hören, denke ich, Papier über Wunder, diese
Art von Ich sagte, wir versuchen irgendwie zu
machen, dass dies alles nur absurd ist
, aber ich denke, der grundlegende
Gedanke ist, dass es einfach absurd ist, dieses Recht zu leugnen.
Egal, was Sie
danach sagen, Sie haben mich irgendwie verloren. Ich bin
nicht in der Lage, L-Kraft zu machen. Denken wir also
über die Kosten und Vorteile nach
, diese Prämisse zu akzeptieren oder abzulehnen,
also fragen Sie nach unvereinbar, sobald
ich sage, dass ich sehr interessiert bin  Die Antwort,
was ist Ihrer Meinung nach falsch
, L jetzt zu leugnen, jede kompatibilistische Leugnung
von L, es wird beinhalten, zwei Behauptungen zu akzeptieren
, dies ist eine viel bessere
Version davon, deshalb hätte ich
sagen sollen, hier ist, was ich auf dem ha habe  Oh,
tut mir leid auf der Folie, wenn ich die Gesetze wüsste, also hat
Louis' Antwort zwei Komponenten,
die erste ist, wenn ich AIDS hätte,
was ich nicht wüsste, wären die Gesetze
anders gewesen, und zweitens hätte ich mir das
vorstellen können  Eine etwas schlampige
Wiedergabe dieses Blicks, es gibt eine
mögliche Handlung, dass erstens
die Gesetze als unvereinbar mit der Person gelten,
zweitens, wenn ich es getan hätte, die Gesetze anders gewesen wären,
drittens, ich in der Lage war, ein
Recht zu finden, Lewis denkt, dass alle diese drei
Dinge sind  wahr, wenn Sie alle eine
Inkompatibilität verteidigen wollen, werden
Sie offensichtlich
dem ersten zustimmen,
richtig, es gibt einige mögliche Maßnahmen
, die mit der Vergangenheit und den
Gesetzen unvereinbar sind. Ich hebe gerade meine Hand,
natürlich werden Sie leugnen  Die dritte
Sache, richtig, Sie werden leugnen, dass ich
gerade meine Hand heben konnte.
Was mich interessiert, ist der
Status dieses zweiten Anspruchs, wenn ich gerade meine
Hand gehoben hätte, wären die Gesetze
anders gewesen  das ist auf  e hier so, und es
scheint mir, dass es zwei Wege gibt, die Sie
gehen könnten, ist, und dann können Sie Glückseligkeit an
diesem Punkt passieren. Zunächst einmal könnten Sie sagen, in
Ordnung, sehen Sie, was falsch daran ist,
dass es nur an uns ist, das zu sagen, wenn ich
es tue  a die gesetze wären genau
so gewesen wie sie tatsächlich sind mit anderen worten
man könnte meinen dass die gesetze einfach nicht
widersprechen hängt möglicherweise davon ab was wir
richtig machen sie sind irgendwie fixiert und wenn ich
etwas anders gemacht habe die gesetze
wäre genauso gewesen, wenn
etwas anders passiert
wäre, die Gesetze wären genauso gewesen,
also könnte das
so sein  könnte
als Inkompatibilität nicht einverstanden sein wäre
auch richtig Sie könnten denken, dass die
Gesetze nicht sachlich davon abhängig sind,
was wir richtig machen
Hand die Gesetze wollen  Ich wäre
anders gewesen, gut, aber das
gibt mir nur Grund zu der Annahme, dass ich nicht in der
Lage war, meine Hände richtig zu heben,
weil dies eine Fähigkeit wäre, etwas zu tun
, das die Gesetze anders machen würde als das,
was sie tatsächlich sind.  Sie sind nicht in der
Lage, die Gesetze zu brechen, also ist die Idee
hier eingefärbt. Okay, sehen Sie, die Gesetze
hängen kontrafaktisch davon ab, was wir tun.
Das mag seltsam klingen, aber es ist in Ordnung,
wir sind nie in der Lage, die Vorläufer dieser Kontrafaktualien zu erkennen.
Wenn ich also sage, schauen Sie, ob  Donald Trump lief unter
neun Punkt,
was ist der Weltrekord, neun Komma sieben
Sekunden, hundert Meter, er wäre der
Weltrekordhalter, der jetzt behauptet, dass es wahr ist, dass es
eine völlig uninteressante Behauptung ist, richtig,
es sagt nicht, dass es auf uns alle zutrifft
, wenn wir rennen würden  Bei neun Komma sieben
Sekunden 100 Meter sind wir der Weltrekordhalter.
Wirklich langweilig, es ist irgendwie
langweilig, weil Donald offensichtlich
nicht in der Lage ist, die Vorgeschichte dieser
Art von Tatsachen zu erkennen, also war Kalebasse einfach
keine sehr interessante Art  von sachlichen
Rechten nur Kontrafaktualien, die
Vorläufer haben, die die Leute nicht erkennen können
, sie sind im Allgemeinen einfach
sehr langweilig, richtig, sie sagen uns
nichts Interessantes, wenn Sie diese
Art von Fraktion aussprechen, von der Sie gesprochen haben, von der ich
keine kenne  Für die Leute, die nicht
ganz der Weltrekordhalter sind, gibt
es Interessanteres zu sagen,
also stellt sich die Frage, ob Sie eine
Unvereinbarkeit sind, die Sie verteidigen möchten, und
wie stehen Sie zu dieser zweiten
Behauptung, wenn ich dabei wäre?  und eins da,
wenn ich gerade meinen arm gehoben hätte, wären die gesetze
anders gewesen, du und ich
akzeptiere diese behauptung und als ob ich das als grund benutze,
um zu sagen, dass du
deine hand nicht heben konntest oder willst
, ja  oder wollen Sie diese Behauptung
mit der Begründung bestreiten, dass die Gesetze nicht
aufheben, tatsächlich von irgendetwas abhängen, was
irgendjemand tut? Lassen Sie uns diese beiden der
Reihe
nach nehmen  sag, schau, dass Anspruch i
Denn wenn ich älter geworden wäre, wären die Gesetze
genau so gewesen, wie sie tatsächlich
sind. Wir
Nords hängen kontrafaktisch davon ab, was wir tun
wäre
vermutlich genau so gewesen, wie sie tatsächlich waren,
wenn Sie bedenken, dass Sie auch
allgemeiner denken werden, dass die
Gesetze nicht davon abhängen, was passiert ist, nicht
nur von dem, was Menschen tun, sondern davon, was
passiert, also wenn meine Uhr nur sollte  Stoppen Sie
jetzt
zum Beispiel, die Gesetze wären
genauso gewesen, wie sie tatsächlich sind
, und das ist eigentlich eine
Abkehr von der Literatur zum freien Willen, und
schauen Sie sich einige der Literatur über Gesetze an
, die behaupten, dass Sätze wie
einer gerade in sind  allgemeines
Falsches wird als Einwand gegen unsere menschliche
Ansicht über Naturgesetze herausgewälzt,
damit Leute, die den Kommunismus nicht mögen,
über Gesetze sagen, ja, es ist diese
Folge des Humanismus,
dass solche Sätze wahr werden, und das ist einfach
seltsam  denn offensichtlich sind sie nicht wahr.
Wenn Sie also diese Behauptung bestreiten,
tun Sie etwas, das
nicht mit Louis 'Antwort auf
das Konsequenz-Argument übereinstimmt, da dies
Teil seiner Antworten ist, um diese Behauptung zu behaupten,
also haben Sie einerseits eine
Antwort  Für Louis großartig, aber es
stimmt auch mit Louis 'ganzer Theorie der Kontrafaktualien überein,
wenn Lewis Leone
Lewis 'Ansicht, ob der Determinismus wahr ist, dann
für so ziemlich jeden nicht tatsächlichen p.
Meine Uhr ist gerade stehen
geblieben  die gesetze wären anders gewesen
rechts
nehmen so ziemlich jede kontingente tatsache
über die welt negiert es
wenn die verneinung dieser tatsachen
der fall gewesen wäre die gesetze wären
anders gewesen wenn ich meine eigenen nicht aufhellen müsste
Babylon in Bezug
auf meine Uhr und Stopp gerade jetzt wären die Gesetze
trotzdem anders gewesen,
aber ich übertreibe es leicht, aber Sie
wissen, dass der einzige vernünftige
Kontofaktor auf dem Tisch der Lou ist  Isiana-
Zählung, das ist diejenige,
nach der diese Behauptung wahr ist, also bin ich da,
das Konto der festen Gesetze, wo Sie
die ganze Vergangenheit variieren, anstatt die Gesetze, über die ich
nicht sprechen werde, die Sie mir stellen können,
ertragen Sie das in Fragen  Wenn Sie so wollen,
wenn Ihr Grund für die Leugnung der
Lewiston-Antwort ist oder Ihr Hauptgrund
ist, dass Sie denken, dass diese
Kontrafaktualität falsch ist, oder Sie denken,
dass die Gesetze nicht zählen
Theorie der
Dose Junggesellen, die unter der
Annahme des Determinismus funktioniert Ich schlage vor, Sie
tun es nicht, und ich denke, das ist ein großer Preis
für Ihre Ansicht, wenn Sie diesen Weg einschlagen wollen
, richtig, wir wissen nicht, wo der
Determinismus wahr ist, wir
und kontrafaktische Rede  Immer, wenn Sie
keine Theorie haben, wie das funktioniert,
sollten wir wirklich eine Theorie haben, die
Sinn macht, okay, also ist eine Art von
kompatibilistischer Antwort, die inkompatibel
ist, die Antwort auf den Lewiston-Einwand gegen
das Konsequenz-Argument I  Denke, bringt
dich in Schwierigkeiten, es kostet etwas,
dort geboren zu werden,
aber es gibt einen anderen Weg, also
lass uns darüber nachdenken  dass, wenn
ich meinen Arm gehoben hätte, die Türen anders gewesen wären,
aber wenn
ich meine eigenen Türen gehoben hätte, wäre
es anders gewesen, offensichtlich kann es nicht
wahr sein, dass ich dann in der Lage gewesen wäre, meinen Arm richtig zu heben,
weil das so wäre  Es stellt
sich heraus, dass wir sagen können, dass wir in der Lage sind,
die Gesetze zu brechen, und dass niemand die Gesetze brechen kann.
Ich denke, das ist der Punkt, an dem wir
in eine Pattsituation geraten, und ich
denke, dass der Kompatibilist an
diesem Punkt nichts zu sagen hat, was den Unkompatibilisten überzeugen könnte
oder umgekehrt, also
sagt der Kompatible nur: Schau, ich sage
nicht, dass wir in der Lage sind, die Gesetze zu
brechen  das ist nicht
das Gleiche, worauf ich Sie verweise  diese
Unterscheidung ist kompatibilistisch Ich nehme
an, dies ist meiner Meinung nach genug davon,
aber inkompatibel sieht nur aus, dass dies als eine
Unterscheidung ohne das andere
ohne einen Unterschied richtig ist,
etwas so tun zu können, dass wir damit
ein Gesetz brechen würden  einfach nicht besser
als in der Lage zu sein, etwas zu tun,
das ein Gesetzesbruch ist, also das
Unvereinbare ist, dass dies hier die Kosten des
Kompatibilismus sind, aber der Kompatibilist
jetzt nicht hier ist meine Ansicht, was es
wert ist, was es dafür wäre  eine
Unterscheidung ohne Unterschied Nun, es
hängt davon ab, nach welcher Art von Unterschied
Sie suchen Ich denke, wenn Sie
nach einer Art tiefem
metaphysischem Unterschied zwischen zwei
Arten von Fähigkeiten suchen, dann der schwachen Fähigkeit und
der starken Fähigkeit, wenn Sie das
wollen  Das ist nicht das, was der
Kompatibilist anbietet, richtig. Ich denke, der
Kompatibilist wie Lewis zum Beispiel
bietet hier eine Unterscheidung an,
und weil es eine Unterscheidung ist, gibt es einen
Unterschied, aber das ist es nicht  Eine tiefe
metaphysische Unterscheidung, die ich kenne, also
Lewis, in Ordnung. Ich denke, wenn Sie
diesen kompatibilistischen
Weg akzeptieren müssen, müssen Sie wahrscheinlich ein Mensch mit
Gesetzen sein, Sie müssen denken, dass das Brechen von
Gesetzen nicht wie die Fähigkeit ist,
Gesetze zu brechen  Ist das nicht richtig, du kennst Magie?
Es ist nur so, was in nahe gelegenen
möglichen Welten passiert. Die Gesetze passen unsere
Motivationen an die Dinge an, die
im Universum passieren. Sie sind einfach nicht
metaphysisch. Sie sind nicht so, wie wir
es in der grundlegenden Struktur der
Realität waren  Ja, die Unterscheidung zwischen
einer schwachen Fähigkeit und einer starken Fähigkeit ist
keine tiefe metaphysische Unterscheidung,
richtig, wenn es das ist, was Sie wollen, dann
ja, Sie werden dort keinen
Unterschied sehen, Sie werden eine
Unterscheidung ohne Unterschied sehen, denke ich,
Louis  sieht einen Unterschied, den Sie kennen,
macht den Unterschied aus,
weil es ein Unterschied ist, von dem ich eigentlich
neige, dass wir den
bestimmten Weg, den er im
Lokal einschlägt, frei brechen können  Gesetze sind nicht der
beste Weg, dies zu tun, weil ich denke, dass
es sich gerade gewendet hat. Ich meine, er schreibt nur vor,
dass wir keine starken Fähigkeiten haben,
richtig, das ist nur geduldiger Louis. Ich
glaube nicht, dass es für sein Buta eine Möglichkeit
gibt, uns so etwas zu geben  ihre Art von Geschichte
darüber, warum diese Bestimmung, warum wir
denken sollten, dass das wahr ist, und ich
denke tatsächlich, dass der Weg zu gehen darin besteht, eine
bedingte Darstellung von Fähigkeiten zu haben, und
dann wird diese Art von Unterscheidung
durch diese Art von Darstellung erzwungen,
aber das ist es  Übrigens, die
Inkompatibilität ist ein Preis für
Kompatibilismus, hier richtig, Sie geben
mir etwas, wo es fällig ist,
dass alles kaputt geht, nur das ist nicht
besser, als etwas tun zu können,
das das Brechen des Gesetzes ist,
sozusagen  beide, nur du, du bist in der
Lage, die Gesetze zu brechen, das weißt du nur
, aber ich glaube nicht, oder zumindest die
Art von Kompatibilismus, die ich bin, und ich
denke, die Art von Kompatibilität, die
Lewis so trug, wie er es nie ausdrücklich
gesagt hat  Alles zu diesem Thema, denke ich,
zumindest wenn Sie ein Mensch über Gesetze sind,
gibt es hier keine Kosten, richtig, Sie haben sich
bereits einer Ansicht über Gesetze angeschlossen,
nach der dies
keine tiefe metaphysische Unterscheidung verankern wird. Es
gibt Möglichkeiten, zu definieren, was  es ist in der
Lage zu sein, dies und das zu tun, dass
sich herausstellt, dass wir das eine können
und
das andere, das ist gut genug,
wir werden hierher getrieben, wenn
Lewis ich denke, wenn Lewis sagt, schau niemandem
zu  in der Lage, ein Wunder zu vollbringen, er
denkt, dass das als Teil des gesunden Menschenverstandes
richtig ist, das ist nur ein Teil unseres
gesunden Menschenverstandes, der ihm die Welt am Herzen liegt, er kümmert sich um den
gesunden Menschenverstand
mit zu viel ist der
gesunde Menschenverstand richtig, also unterstützt er die
Meinungen des gesunden Menschenverstands, also muss es so
sein, dass wir keine Wunder vollbringen können,
aber es ist ihm egal
, warum das so ist  ist richtig, er will nur
drücken  Es ist gesunder Menschenverstand, und ich denke, das ist
nicht das, was mit dem Unvereinbaren los ist,
wenn überhaupt, was
Mitgefühl will, um zu kaufen,
dass die Unterscheidung ein richtiger tiefer
metaphysischer Unterschied ist, und es ist
einfach nicht in Ordnung, also eine
Schlussfolgerung, wenn wir darüber nachdenken  Die Sache, die so
viel in einem Louis-Ian-Geist tut, ist
die inkompatibilistische Verpflichtung zu dieser
Prämisse Ich kann die Gesetze nicht
erzwingen, wie folgt: Wir haben zwei
Möglichkeiten. Die erste Option besteht darin, die
kontrafaktische Abhängigkeit der Gesetze von
was zu leugnen  Ich denke, es hat definitiv seinen
Preis, dass Sie keine Theorie der
Kontrafaktualitäten haben, die schlecht ist. Die andere
Sache, die Sie tun könnten, ist, an
der Idee festzuhalten, dass die Gesetze kontrafaktisch
davon abhängen, was wir tun, und nur Sie wissen,
dass Sie darauf bestehen  Bestehen Sie darauf, dass wir aus diesem
Grund diese Dinge nicht
richtig machen können, denn wenn das Gesetz
tatsächlich davon abhängt, was wir tun, dann sollten wir
besser nicht in der Lage sein, etwas anderes zu tun,
denn dann wären wir in der Lage, solche Dinge zu
tun  weh  Uld stellt einen Verstoß gegen Gesetze dar
, wenn dieser Anspruch nicht vereinbar ist. Oh, wenn ich hier sagen würde, ja,
natürlich hat das freie Recht ein Leistungsrecht,
das Sie verweigert haben. Sie können das tun
, was
die Gesetze wären, wenn Sie es tun würden  anders, das hat einen
guten Vorteil, nicht in der Lage, die Gesetze zu brechen,
brillant, das ist das Ergebnis, das wir wollen, wenn
wir ein Kompatibilist einer inkompatiblen
Liste einer bestimmten Art sind, also kreuzen Sie
frei, um diesen Weg zu gehen, großartig aus
Wettbewerbssicht, es ist die 13
das behauptete, dass es das Gehirn kostet
, etwas zu tun, so wie
sie es getan haben, ein Lord of Orokin,
es ist absolut in Ordnung, vielleicht muss
man ein Mensch sein, was Gesetze angeht, um damit einverstanden zu sein
, aber ich sehe das nicht so
Kosten, und Lewis hätte es nicht
als Kosten gesehen, hat auch einen massiven Nutzen.
Determinismen sind eigentlich kein Hindernis.
Natürlich, wenn Sie jemanden wie Det Pair Segen hätten, würden Sie das
eher als Kosten denn als Nutzen betrachten, aber
dazu tendieren Kompatibilisten  Denke zehn  d zufrieden zu sein
, aber es stellt sich heraus, dass der freie Wille
eher mit Determinismus vereinbar
als enttäuscht ist, also denke ich, dass wir jetzt in
dieser Position sind, es ist die etwas weniger
feindselige Version dieser Position, ob
es einen Preis gibt, der damit verbunden ist, diese Behauptung zu behaupten
oder zu leugnen ist es nicht  etwas
, das Sie meiner Meinung nach feststellen können, was die
Kosten und Vorteile sind, was
Sie nicht unabhängig voneinander feststellen können, eine
ganze Menge anderer philosophischer Ansichten haben,
dass Sie eine Menge
anderer Dinge haben, richtig, wir brauchen eine Theorie der
Kontrafaktualien, Sie könnten ein Mensch sein
oder eine nichtmenschliche Ansicht über Naturgesetze, von der
Sie wissen, dass Sie vielleicht eine Meinung darüber haben,
ob freies Handeln eine gute oder
eine schlechte Sache ist. All diese
Dinge werden Ihre Einstellung dazu beeinflussen,
ob dies ein Kostümvorteil ist oder
nicht  Es war eine unabhängige
Art, diese Fragen zu bestimmen, indem wir
nur wirklich hart auf das
Argument der Konsequenzen starrten, das
Ihnen überhaupt nicht helfen wird
breiter als das, und ich denke, es
kann einfach nicht sozusagen von einem
neutralen Standpunkt aus festgestellt werden, wer die
größten Kosten zu tragen hat, denn ob
Sie glauben, Kosten oder Nutzen zu tragen,
hängt von der Ausgangsposition ab
mit
so einem Patt, das ist mein Fazit